Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
Today, I'm continuing my exploration
of Spin.
Spin is a microservice
framework
for web assembly applications
from the team at Fermion.
I've already done a quick exploration where I
wrote my first spin service,
and that was done two weeks ago on
this channel, search for spin, and you'll find
it. Feel free to go and watch that
before following on with this one.
This video, we're taking that initial application to
the next level.
What does a full stack
spin app look like?
So before we continue, we'll cover a few
things. One,
what do I mean by full stack? Well,
I mean, we have a website that has
been delivered by Fermion Cloud.
It has one or more API available to
it on the back end to do some
random arbitrary calculation of some kind,
And we can make the request from
the website to the API, deliver results for
the user.
Typically,
we're delivering a front end client to the
user through the website. We have an API
on the back end. Each API endpoint is
going to be its own spin component.
Now
one more caveat on that list of caveats
I wanna give you is that please do
not judge me for my code.
So the purpose
of today's demo
is to show you what the structure
of a multi component full stack spin application
looks like. Not necessarily the best way to
write a web for it or the best
way to write the API endpoint and rust
or grain.
I'm still learning this stuff.
So I'm not overly proud of the code.
However, it's a proof of concept. I wanted
to see what this looked like end to
end and what that developer experience felt like.
But I'm gonna show you all this. I
will publish the code to GitHub,
and I'm I'm glad actually, I'm gonna continue
to improve this.
Now
that I have
something that works,
I wanna,
you know what what but I'm prototyping. Right?
What I like to do is is make
it work.
Then I'll make it right, and then I'll
make it fast. This is this three step
adage that we've all heard as developers over
the last ten years, twenty years, however long
you've been doing this. I've made it work.
I actually really wanna use Spin for
some real applications.
You may have seen a video on the
academy last year, but I actually broke down
how all of the automation works for the
YouTube Academy.
And I wanna rebuild that in a cloud
native way with bits of web assembly scattered
through it. So I'm now wondering how do
I loop this in my automation. And I'm
gonna be rebuilding a lot of this. I'm
gonna start to do this the right way.
Spending a little bit more time not being
ashamed of my code and shipping it.
And then we'll talk about performance. I'm gonna
do another video on Fairman Cloud in a
couple of weeks where we look at what
the performance characteristics of this spend
development life cycle and workflow and production deployments
look like.
But that's the caveat stunt. Not proud of
the code. It does work. I'm gonna do
it more. I'm gonna make it right. So
I hope you're comfortable and happy with that
as I am.
I see we have a comment from Russell
in the chat.
Yeah. I do have a new video style.
I decided
to experiment a little bit. So I'm not
in my new office yet. I move into
my new office over the next couple of
days.
And as part of my new office,
I bought some new goodies. Some new green
screens, some new lighting, a whole bunch of
other things. None of that is set up
today, but it did make me pull out
all the stuff that I previously had to
kinda do a bit of stock and inventory.
And I decided to try and make this
a little bit more interactive.
And in fact, when we switch over
to the screen share, I'm in the corner,
we have the code.
I mean, I I think there's some merit
to this style, especially when it's just me
this year.
You know, I'm gonna try and focus on
getting the screen bigger and the text bigger
and me being able to interact with that.
I can't quite point to code yet, but,
you know,
as bigger green screens come, better lighting comes,
opens up new options. So, yeah, I'm experimenting.
Feel free to give me a thumbs up
or a thumbs down, Russell and anyone else
who's watching.
Now, this video, we're gonna spend the next
I'm not sure how long this be, twenty
minutes, twenty five minutes.
Taking a look at this application that I've
built.
A good thing that I'd like to build
as part of a here's how to build
distributed systems is a calculator,
where each service within the calculator is an
operation plus, minus, multiplication,
division,
cosine,
etcetera.
Today's is very simple. I've only implemented
addition and subtraction
very crudely, I may add. And I bet
you're going there. How can you implement subtracting
crudely? Okay. You're gonna see.
There's one other service here which I haven't
built yet, but as I go on and
make this right,
we are going to implement that. And I'll
probably do that one live actually because I'm
getting a lot more comfortable with the process
of Build to Spin application.
So let's just take a look. What we
have here is the calculator service. This is
the one that's not built and the one
that we will build together.
This is the one that's gonna take some
arbitrary
equation from the user via the front end
application
and
parse it. Build a
build a bunch of tokens that describe what
that equation looks like, so those can be
divided into operations and sent off to the
relevant microservices.
Potentially,
if we build the DAG of this, we
can do this highly concurrent, which would be
very, very cool.
But that's the make it right part, not
the part we're looking at today. So it's
currently empty. It's just the hello world rust
application.
But I do think we'll do this one
together because I think it will be a
whole lot of fun.
We have config and content,
modules,
scripts,
static,
and templates.
These are all part of Bartholomew.
This is the content management and front end
application.
This is a river project. This is the
main entry point for the user.
It has a markdown rendering to the front
end application.
I've written some very good JavaScript to make
the API endpoints to the back end.
As I was doing this, I realized there's
actually nothing stopping me from yeah. I can
use which
has some cool characteristics,
and I don't need to build
like an NPM run build or anything like
like a lit like a with Next.
And because the web assembly module handles everything
for our service.
But honestly, if I don't want that and
I'm not that tied to that approach, there's
no reason that this application couldn't be an
XGS application because
works
with Spin's file server component.
So as long as I can do an
NPM run build on an XGS application and
get a disk folder, I can serve that
over the file server component as well. So
depending on what you're looking to do,
I started very simple today with Bartholomew and
you'll see just what I mean. But I
think the next version of this where we
sit down and do this right, we'll see,
okay. What is the
status quo front end web development? Is it
next? Is it SvelteKit? Is it something else?
Remix? Astro?
Let's use that. Build it into the build
the pipeline,
and actually deliver over the failed server component.
And I think that'll be really interesting. So
I'm looking forward to doing that.
Lastly, we have two services here in the
middle, math minus and math plus.
These are two individual services deployed as web
assembly modules.
Again, the code is not great, but one
handles the subtraction. I don't know why didn't
call it mass subtraction. One handles the subtraction
operation and the other one handles the addition
or some operation.
So that's that's our structure. I
think as I build more of these, this
is gonna become my kind of my my
standard layout and kind of put that web
application, the user facing one first, top level.
I guess I could nest it in some
way. Maybe I'll explore that when I do
next JS stuff.
And my only regret with this layout is
that I didn't put math minus and plus
into a services folder, but again, that would
be really easy to do. And in fact,
we could do that live on the stream
if anyone even wants to see what that
looks like and what I need to update
to make that work, just say hey and
we'll make that happen.
So let's take a look at Bartholomew first.
So I do have
my application here.
What I love about Bartholomew is that we
have a content directory,
which does path based routing
and markdown generation.
Now I am going
to delete all this code for a few
minute. Hopefully not lose that on my paste
buffer actually. Let's just do that.
And say hello Spin and we'll just change
this to be hello Rawkode
live.
So we'll save this. We're gonna come back
over here to warp and I'm going to
run a Spin
up and a follow all, which will just
give me the logs to my terminal.
You've seen this on the previous spin video
if you saw that. If not,
no problem.
And we can see here each of the
services that we have deployed. We've got Bartholomew
available on Port 3000, which actually takes a
wildcard group. It's gonna listen to all paths
on slash that don't match any other path.
We then have our static fail server as
part of Bartholomew, which listens to slash static,
also a wildcard. So anything after that will
be delivered via the static fail system.
This is the same module, which I think
and but I know will deliver a Next.
Js or any other front end application
pretty nicely.
We have the calculator which we're not using,
and then Math plus and Math minus. I've
hidden them under an API endpoint
with the Math plus and Math
math parameter
on the path.
Now these are not sophisticated endpoints. I'm using
the query URL
to parse the the arguments that we passed
to each operation. The reason I did it
that way is when we look at the
Grain code, you'll see I had a few
challenges because I'd never written Grain before
and not just my own inability to write
Grain but
the standard library is still very early with
Grain.
I focused
on consistency of the parsing techniques rather than
in the Rust ecosystem jumping off, grabs and
creates, doing some proper parsing. Was like, you
know what? We'll just keep it crude on
both and then it's gonna be very similar.
So we can pop open our browser.
You can see I've already tried to have
local host on 3,000.
And here we go.
Let's zoom in. This is the standard
Bartholomew
theme and slots. We've got a sidebar. We've
some length. We've got the kind of attributions
here and then we've got Hello Rawkode live.
We could make changes to this if we
really wanted to. We can go into the
template.
We can look at main
and we can start to change this up.
This is gonna feel very similar to Hugo.
If you've used Hugo before and you come
from the go background and the go ecosystem,
we have templates, they have slots, we inject
stuff into the slots, we deliver a website.
That's it.
Simple. Right? Cool.
Now, I'm gonna bring back all of my
horrendous code.
And we're not gonna look at it just
yet.
Now, when we ran, spin up,
oh, we've got our logs. We can follow
along with everything that's happening too.
Hey. Russell says, more suppose
I can't speak to you. More space for
code, the better when you dive into it.
Yeah. I I think so. I'm looking forward
to, you know,
I shouldn't really move it now, but, you
know, been able to make this a bit
bigger, pull it over my face and not
lose too much, but there's still some tweaks
that need to be happening.
Cool. Yeah. So
we also have these other routes. So what
do those look like? Well, when we run
spin up, we get everything.
So we can pop open a new terminal
and we can run curl v API.
Fast.
Math minus,
and we'll get a 500.
Now my error handling is not great, has
to be better, but I know because I
wrote it that if we pass a question
mark for a query string
and two integers separated by a comma,
worst API ever of course. But I didn't
want to handle JSON parsing
and Grain because guess what? There is no
JSON parsing and Grain yet, which would make
you wonder why did I use Grain?
I was curious.
Probably won't stay in it for much longer.
However,
if we do a five and two,
we get a result of three.
So this is me
actually printing
JSON from
the Grain language, hence the extremely weird formatting.
With that being said, I think we should
look at the Grain code.
So let's pop open Math minus
and we have our main dot GR.
Now
there's a lot to love about Grain and
that is a truly WebAssembly native language and
that the only target is WebAssembly.
But it's a very early language as well.
It's currently on 0.5
I think.
There's lots of things just don't exist in
the ecosystem but you know what? It was
it was a whole lot of fun learning
the language and playing with it and I
actually I'm really excited to where it's gonna
be
in six months and twelve months time.
But not something I would ship to production.
Not today.
So
borrows a lot from the JavaScript
ecosystem and the Node. Js ecosystem and we
have import statements which then have a from
on the end.
We can, if we wish,
break this down and say that we only
want the two list function, but
based on the way that I have all
the code below, we're importing the entire package
so that we can call the functions and
properties of it.
I define a record, we're not using the
record, again, I was trying to marshal this
to JSON, but it doesn't really exist yet,
but it was fun to define a record.
We just say record and we give it
a name and then we describe it much
like a JSON object in JavaScript,
which I thought was quite nice.
And even though it's a really early language,
with Grain, we do get decent
integration with Versus Code. So we can kinda
see the same information here, but at least
it shows me that an LSP is trying
its best. So maybe more is gonna come
soon.
Down here, we can actually see the Rx
is an array of string, which we wouldn't
normally know. So the LSP did very well
there.
And what I really liked was throwing around
expect functions on results and options,
something that we can do in Rust,
but in the Grain language. So here I'm
actually saying,
we want to get the arguments.
So we're using argv
and this grain model or grain code, I'm
not sure what we call it and
if we don't get what we expect we're
gonna fail with failed to parse arguments
and what we're trying to actually do here
is pull out argv and we expect an
array of string.
So as long as we get some array
of strings of arguments,
we will pass the first check.
We then wanna pull them out. I've just
called this indices, but we're doing a
turn this array into a list
and then we're using the list semantics rather
than the array semantics that probably could just
have used array dot pop and then to
list on that. However,
I did the list dot drop which drops
one element from the list.
Next, I'm getting the equation,
which is
not really what we're doing. However, it'll do
for now. And all I'm doing here is
saying that I wanna pull out the first
value of the list. So I'm using list
dot n.
We this
actually gives me
something
like this.
Next,
we do a string dot split on the
comma and then array to list, we're pulling
it back to a list and then we're
using pars and on the nth element get
out. So these two code boxes are the
exact same. As you can tell,
this is a lot harder than Grain than
it would be in any other language, but
I felt committed at this point and I
wanted to see what this looked like. Because
when we use and build spin applications,
we could use any language that compels the
web assembly.
And that's fun. Right? I could have used
Swift, it'd probably been two lines of code.
I could have used Rust, it would have
been four or five lines of Could've used
Java, Scala, Clojure, any JVM language, any dot
net language, etcetera. However,
I was committed to this point.
So we're doing number dot parse in and
we're doing an option expect where we expect
to get some and to do back from
the center result expect
wrapping it.
Once we've done all the heavy lifting there
of parsing two things on the command line
or query string, we have to print the
headers, which is content type application JSON and
then I'm manually printing the JSON.
Now the challenge and why this had to
be
three print statements
is really funny.
It's because I couldn't do interpolation
or even concatenation
here
because there's no way to get a string
from a number in green. At least I
could not find out how to convert a
number to a string.
So instead of having a single print statement,
we had to have three and you can't
print without printing a new line in green.
At least I couldn't work it out, Which
is why we have this very awkwardly looking
JSON syntax.
However,
we don't need to save this.
As you can tell from here,
it works.
We do do we do pass five comma
two, we get a subtraction and the value
of two or the difference depending on what
you wanna call it.
In the same vein, we can run math
plus.
And we can say five and two and
we get result dot seven or result equals
seven and a proper JSON string with no
arbitrary
random new lines. And why is this? Well,
because our plus
function
is implemented in Rust.
Here,
we are using the Spin SDK, which is
quite nice. We are able to use a
procedural macro around our function, which says this
is the entry point or application that handles
all the glue.
We grab the URI query. We do a
string split. We do a map, convert it
to a u 64 n and then we
sum it up.
A lot nicer than the green approach.
Still a little bit awkward.
I shouldn't really need to parse the query
string. I should be able to pass in
a JSON body, serialize that out. That would
all work just fine but because I did
that the grain way,
that is what I went with.
From here, we're just doing a JSON object
of result sum and then spend it back
out here
with the response builder.
Much nicer. This is easier code to test.
I could extrapolate some of this to functions
that I really wanted to handle the query
string and the sums.
But however,
for a simple rust function and under 25
lines of code, this works really well.
So
we have two a two API endpoints that
work. They do addition and subtraction,
and we have a website. Well, let's take
a look at the website.
If I jump back over here and we
just
spin this back up again. And that's just
because I was messing around with HTML and
Bartholomew.
There's no live hot reloading. I
don't think so. Maybe that's a flag.
But if we jump back to the web
browser,
we have this. So,
hey, my lease just went out.
Okay. We have this. I've got a form
where we pass in number 10
and another number
76.
And we have this drop down where we
can see whether we want addition or subtraction.
So let's do addition first and we hit
submit and we get 86.
If I swap this round and do five
minus 12,
we get minus seven.
Now,
when we build this right
and we continue to, you know, make this
distributed calculator a bit more useful. What I
actually wanna be able to do
is,
you know, do the bot mass thing. Like,
what happens if we have
proper queries?
And what's gonna happen is the calculate function
will parse all this, build a token of
it, ship them off to the services, bring
it back and spit out the result.
That's where we're gonna be in a couple
of weeks. But for today,
you're getting 56 or fifty five fifty six
minus 12.
What does this look like from a code
point of view? Well, this is pretty standard
HTML and JavaScript.
Although it's my version of standard, it's not
a front end developer, so it's not exactly
nice.
However, inside of our index dot m d,
we can embed
script tags and other HTML tags. We're not
constrained,
but only markdown, which I thought was quite
nice.
So we define a really simple form,
which has an idea form. We turn off
the default submit handler so that we don't
refresh the page. We do that with on
submit equals return false.
We have an input for property one and
property two and then a select for the
operation.
That drop down should be between the values
for your exabyte.
I know it's not nice. I know. I
know. We're gonna make it right just not
in today's video.
And then we have a submit function.
I can't even spell results. So why don't
we fix that while we're here? And then
we have this empty span and paragraph where
we're gonna push the result from the response
of the API.
Next, we open up some script tags. We're
just defining a function to submit the form.
Now because this is just in the browser,
Bartholomew
as web assembly and that the server runs
on web assembly, it generates the HTML, but
the HTML still runs in your browser.
So we have access to all the browser
APIs,
which means we can do a fetch call.
We use the fetch API and we're just
doing some local run to slash API slash
math
with a horrible
operator to flip the operation from plus to
minus. Of course, we need to make that
better. Yes, Russell. It is tech debt.
Hold on. Let me pop that on the
screen.
Wanna
hide your critique.
I'll
try not to make it too small. There
we go. It is tech debt, but we're
gonna make it right.
So we send this off. We say that
this is a JSON response by using the
first promise
then we pull it out here. So I've
got some really crude console dot logs, make
sure that my thing was working.
And then we're using result dot enter dot
enter HTML,
set the data as a result.
Next, we just hook up the form listener.
So we're grabbing the form by the ID
and adding the event listener.
It was when I was putting all this
HTML and JavaScript together that I realized we
have really good frameworks for this. And if
we wanna build interactive
client side applications,
I would probably use SvelteKit or I would
use Next or Astro or
Remix. I think that's the four ones that
I played with and like to some degree.
At least they make my JavaScript not terrible.
And I was like, well,
I wonder if I can deliver that like
this.
So that's my next improvement. And in fact,
the next time we do the stream, we'll
be hooking in an existing JavaScript framework
with a build pipeline
and having that deployed with spend fail server
API or web assembly module.
So that's the next step. Then
we build the calculate service. And then we'll
do that live. We'll do that. We'll have
some fun.
But this works.
This is a working full stack application. And
I'm really happy with this. The code sucks,
but I think it shows
the
convenience that Spin can provide.
I get the same developer experience.
And you'll see here, this is me doing
a spin up.
When I'm happy with that, I can just
run a spin deploy.
And if we give that ten seconds or
so, in fact, there we go, we now
have this endpoint.
If I just click this,
we have my application
posted on Fermion Cloud where I can do
a 12
to minus
result.
And that makes me happy.
So
that is a full stack spin application
with a pretty nice developer experience,
very simple production,
with some notable rooms for improvement.
So I hope you like what you see.
I'll give you thirty seconds to throw any
questions into the comment.
But the next steps for this proof of
concept
are bringing in
hold on. I hate my green screen. Bringing
in a
JavaScript framework. I think I'm gonna use Astro.
It's the one I've been using to build
out the academy website.
So I I wanna see how what I
can do with it. And it also does
very nice static state generation very similar to
Bartholomew.
I think where Bartholomew shines us in the
same way that Hugo shines. Right? If you
don't have
a lot of
heavy JavaScript client side logic,
you just wanna take markdown content and render
it
as a a website, a static website for
documentation and other needs, our volume is gonna
be great.
But when we want to start interacting with
more spend components and services as API endpoints,
I think let's just start to leverage all
of this.
That's step one. And then step two, we
build the calculator.
Alright.
So thank you, Russell. Looking forward to the
CDs. I'm really enjoying playing with Spin. So,
you know, I can already see lots of
use cases for it. And I I love
WebAssembly anyway.
And so I'm gonna experiment more more languages.
I think we'll bring in a little bit
of Swift maybe for the calculate method. I'm
not sure.
Maybe some Scala. I'm feeling a little bit
brave.
But, yeah, I won't forget the logging and
I'm glad you're enjoying the series.
Alright.
Well, thank you all for tuning in.
Hopefully, that gives you an understanding of what
a full stack spin application looks like.
I think the structure works really well. I'm
now in a position where we could start
to lay it on more and more services.
We can use local based routing
with the services, which is nice. You know,
the web browser just had to call slash
API.
We're gonna layer on more of this. And
then when we're finished the calculator, I think
we'll time about something real for my real
Rawkode Academy automation.
So thank you for tuning in. I'll see
you all soon.
Have a wonderful day.
Adios.